okay hi everyone so we have a lot of
material to get through and not a lot of
time so I'm gonna rush a little bit this
is an actual talk that I gave at PI D to
Delhi as a keynote but it didn't get
recorded so I asked the PI data deli
chairs if I could present it again so we
had a recording of it a lot of work has
been put into this talk but I want to
give you the context of this talk so I
was on line on one of those linked a
grater sites like hacker news the other
day and I saw a link to the 500 best
Python talks and it was some really
junky domain like best Python talks biz
or something and I went through it and I
looked for the best talks and I've given
probably this is like my 90 95th
conference talk in the last five years
so I thought maybe I'll find one of my
own there be a nice little ego boost so
I look you know intro Python talks
nothing of mine talked about C Python
nothing of mine
talked about numpy or numeric or
scientific computing nothing of mine
talks about embedding Python one
interpreters into Python two
interpreters into Python three
interpreters using linker namespaces
these avi dlm open nothing I'm the only
one who's ever done that and and so I I
said to myself you know the ego and the
vanity of this maybe it doesn't matter
and so I parked that for a second and
then a couple days later there was
another link on Hacker News and it was
you know please post your favorite
YouTube videos of all time the best
computer science or programming talks
you ever see and I was looking through
that list I saw all these seminal
presentations that had really changed
the face of computer science of software
development and I was hoping none of my
talks would appear on that list because
I don't think I've made a contribution
that significant and thankfully none of
my talks appear there but it reminded me
of something very important which is I
don't care about the ego I don't care
about the fame I just like to have a
little bit of fun and so I thought why
don't I put together a talk that will
never appear on one of those lists ever
because it's the most garbage useless
talk ever that's what this is so before
we get started we're at PI D to NYC it's
Thursday October 18 2008 een this is dot
dot dot you know one thing that I've
thought about you give enough talks you
always think about doing a twitch stream
like scope at Sears has tried doing or a
live cast or a web cast but the problem
with doing those on YouTube
is you have to you have to be really
good at that part where they say please
like subscribe L and comment and I can't
bring myself to be that enthusiastic so
here's me on Twitter you can follow me
or or not I don't really care but if
you'd like to go ahead this is the talk
okay so one thing that's really
important about this talk is there is no
theme to this talk please please please
there is no theme to this talk you may
look at this talk and say well there's
obviously a theme it's about how the joy
of discovery the joy of digging deep
into a problem is something that nobody
can take from you that there's a certain
pleasure and understanding something
very full yet only when you think you
have mastered that topic you realize
there's even further to go
nope that's not the theme this talk has
no meaning but it is contextualized in
terms of a story I know many of you out
there are very precocious and you may
have had an experience just like the one
I'm about to describe so imagine your
first day of your first job you did a
PhD you two masters you did a boot camp
computer science you show up to work and
your boss says welcome to our company
we're so glad to have a young kid like
you joining us today we're a company we
do scientific computing in fact we work
in the optical industry and in the fiber
optics industry we really need people
who know about software so it's great
that you learned Python in school we're
trying to transform this industry I'm
gonna start you with a really simple
task we'll work on the backend of our
system
maybe we're building reconfigurable
optical add-drop multipliers rotom's
or some other optical hardware we'll
start with something kind of simple why
don't you write a function that converts
wavelength to optical frequency and you
say oh my goodness are you serious like
I just did a PhD and you're asking me to
do that that's just C divided by the
lambda or C divided by the new serious
but your boss comes to you and they
start you off with a little code sample
and the code sample looks something like
this and they say you know what what we
want you to do if you're following along
is write wavelength to frequency it
takes a frequency and just fill in the
blank there and I'll put a comment up
here to tell you what I'm working on
converts wavelength to optical frequency
and we want you to fill in the blank
there and you're looking down you're
like really my first day did you not
read my resume I can do a little bit
more than that and your boss comes to
you and he says or
he says because remember condescension
transcends gender please come on
take the task and do it and when they
write this out they might write it out
like that or they might write this and
we'll save this you can see it runs on
the side not implemented error or maybe
they're a little bit clever than you
thought and they did a docstring here
instead of a comment and that works as
well or they might do this and you look
at that you say that's kind of weird
what is that dot and thinking about the
task and you say oh my goodness they
really asked me to do this and so you
say well you know what I'm pretty smart
I'll just do this right and if they ask
me to actually give it the name they
said I'll just do that or you know what
I'll just do that right and you know
what I'm so smart I could just do this
because I know that two formulas are the
same right it's either C divided by
lambda or C divided by nu it's the same
either way so it's not too hard but you
know what they're really asking for what
they're asking for something that looks
more like this you know they want you to
write it all the way out the wavelength
to the frequency converts wavelengths to
optical frequency and you know they're
really hardcore on documenting
everything so maybe we actually even use
swings here so you do parabola so my
goodness is so tedious I can't believe I
spent that much money on grad school for
this seriously and you return returns
the optical frequency and it feels like
this is taking you an hour and you look
at the clock and it's taking about three
minutes and you're like okay you know
they asked me to do both versions of it
so Tina will just do both versions and
this is just too much right this is too
much I can cut my I can cut and paste my
way to completing this this assignment
and you just wonder what kind of choices
have you made in life to lead you to
here there we go did I do that right
and you save it and it works and it kind
of does what you think it would do but
that one question stays with you that
dot dot dot how did that work that was
kind of weird and so your precocious and
you're curious and you're not really
fulfilled by the task that you're doing
here because clearly it took us about 30
seconds and I'm on stage right now so
you start digging and the first place
you dig is what documentation but you're
a smart kid so you know documentation is
not enough you always have to dig into
the code what it makes sense to start
with the documentation so maybe you
start with the documentation or maybe
you start by just googling it and you
find this post from 2006 guido van
rossum he's responding to Greg Ewing
saying pi3k this is when python 3 was
just coming out MCDOT a generally legal
expression and you might track this a
little bit further and you might see
this post from 2 years later where
Raymond and Guido are discussing the dot
dot and Guido says some folks thought it
would be cute to be able to write
incomplete code like this and so you say
okay so my boss wasn't doing anything
too crazy I mean they intended this but
you still are very curious about that
dot dot dot now you may have seen
something like that before
you may remember from you know when you
type it into your type Python
interpreter you get this ellipses and
you may have seen something like that
before you can kind of guess that you've
seen similar ideas to this with your
sorry with your true/false and none and
you may have even seen this in use you
know if you take an umpire and DRA that
represents a matrix like this you know a
five by five matrix you know you can
index it with your fancy indexing and
you can do like that and that gets you
whoops let's do the first row that gets
you the first row and you know if this
happens to be a three dimensional
structure so we'll make this a little
bit bigger like that you can do this
kind of indexing similarly you can do
one dot dot dot but that's kind of the
same thing as doing one colon which is
maybe a syntax with a slice operator or
the slice object then you've seen before
and you may even know that if you just
do one here you get the same result but
there's something kind of special to
this dot dot dot at least in numpy
because well that gives you one of the
play
of this cube that gives you a different
plane of the cube so there's something
kind of interesting how numpy actually
deals with this dot it's not quite
equivalent to the colon but you know if
you were really cared about it you could
read you could read through the
documentation for numpy but you're
really just curious about this syntax
because it turns out that this is Python
this is valid Python syntax and what's
interesting is that means that this is
valid Python syntax right and if that's
valid Python syntax then we know that
that's valid Python syntax now if that's
valid Python syntax then we know that
this is valid Python syntax right and we
can space that out to make it look a
little bit better and we know that this
is valid Python syntax as well now we're
beginning to look like something kind of
cool and we know we can just keep going
and going and if we really want to we
can even determine that we could add in
a couple of underscores here and here
except that'll break because when it
tries to actually perform when it tries
to actually compute that annotation
it'll try and do the dotted lookup with
an underscore and attribute and ellipses
doesn't have one of those but you're
smart you follow Python dev you know we
were in Python three seven so there we
go we can say from future import
annotations move that to the top of the
file and that's about python syntax as
well and that's kind of cool and you try
this a little bit further and you say
well let me try something simpler how
about that that's not valid Python
syntax well what's going on here let's
try something even simpler that's not
valid Python syntax something kind of
strange is happening here but you look
at the time it's five o'clock it's time
to go home
let's visit this another day you come
back the next day and they look at the
code review and they are abused err so
happy oh my goodness we're so happy we
hired you you know they said we don't
necessarily need somebody who's young we
need a senior programmer but you knock
that to wavelength to frequency and
frequency the wave IQ that's it out of
the park so we're gonna give you a
little bit more exposure to the systems
we have you know we develop rotom's we
develop full fully to full devices so
you know you did some back-end yesterday
let's do some front-end today and so we
have this little front-end and it has
some greetings because as you may know
the optical industry is our world is a
global industry there's a lot of people
who are experts in optical engineering
in the US and germ
in France and Italy in China and India
and so they start you off with and let
me rewind a little bit because we you're
seeing some of the results of where we
go they start you off with something
that looks like this
and they say we want you to extend this
and we want you to add some of the other
languages that we deal with right and
here we have English and German and we
think you're smart you can probably
follow the pattern and you're looking at
you're like oh my goodness do you not
know how much I have in student loans
and you are asking me oh my goodness and
you call your friend you're like is your
job as bad as this and it turns out it's
like that everywhere but you know you
say what can I do and so you you add
this in okay and you submit that as a
code review and when you come back from
lunch your boss is furious because it
turns out your boss irrespective of
gender is French and they look at that
and they say salte cinnapup wants a safe
home okay because it turns out that
we'll see you have there is not the
right see if you're spelling french what
you need is you need a little see what
little squiggly underneath and this is
something that French people care a
whole lot about except when it comes to
emails and we'll talk about that in a
second I don't understand that either
but they say you know what you're a new
hire we can requisite some new hardware
for you so you know we're gonna do we're
gonna requisition a fancy new keyboard
I'm gonna give you a keyboard that does
that ooh that's kind of neat and you
have a really fancy keyboard because
your keyboard can even do this let's do
this
and never swing okay and what do look at
that and you have a you have I mean this
is this is a pretty this is a pretty
expensive keyboard they got you and you
can even do this and this is hard for me
to type there we go but and if you can't
read that this is just let's see it's
just uh there we go
that's how you pronounce it and so you
have your fancy keyboard now you've
implemented quite a bit of functionality
here but you know a little bit more I
mean you've you've you've study a little
bit of Python in school and you know
that you can write it like this or you
can write it like this you can pass
these as keyword arguments right whoops
and all you have to do is just change
these colons to equal signs and you know
that's valid Python too and that's kind
of interesting because any one of these
ID dictionary keys as long as it's a
valid variable name in Python works very
well and that gets you thinking for a
second well that's kind of interesting
right I mean cuz that means that that
means that that's a valid variable
Python name it's a VAT that's a valid
variable name of Python well it's kind
of interesting and when you think about
that a little bit more you say well you
know that's a valid variable name in
Python then that means I can even do
something like this
right that's valid Python right nobody
here gets the joke does anyone get the
joke you get the joke yeah but that's
that's a that's about we'll clean this
up here makes you make this work that's
a valid variable name in Python and you
say to yourself you know this is a
really fancy keyboard I can actually
type a dot dot dot on the keyboard so I
can actually do that
and I wonder if I visit my example from
yesterday I can do that
no that's invalid well that's kind of
curious and if you go a little bit
further you might say let's do that
that's invalid as well and we'll pull
this line off so you can see that's
invalid as well so there's something
here that you're missing now you're very
smart and you learn a little bit about
computer science in school and you say
you know I know Python is driven by a
grammar so you go into the grammar file
and Python you can see all the details
of how the Python grammar works and you
can answer some of the questions that
you found by just digging at this layer
here you can see part of the Python
grammar the specification that's not
only a specification for how Python
parses itself but is actually used as
part of the code generated parser it's
actually used as part of not only the C
Python code that parses your code but
also the Python library that can give
you parsing support and you can see
there's this atom thing and you can
probably assume that that atom thing
represents the smallest unit as part of
some expression and you can see a name a
number a string and an explicit dot none
true or false or all special case
they're all separate from each other and
if you go further you can see that
there's this expression statement that's
what happens on the left and right hand
side of the equal sign but you can't see
anything here that actually stops you
from assigning to that dot and you might
begin to wonder what's stopping me from
doing that assignment to the dot either
in the first case I saw yesterday or in
the recent case I saw today
now you might know that Python allows
you to parse itself it's a really neat
thing about Python your Python
distribution come to it the parser that
allows you to parse Python code which is
why Python tooling is so great because
in a tool like my my IDE here I can
actually use the current version of
Python that I'm writing code in to also
verify that the code that I'm writing is
syntactically valid well here you might
say well I can pour something like this
and see oops
let's do I can part something like that
and that works and I can parse something
like this is my sorry is my Python 2
parser we got to be a little bit careful
there we go I can parse something that
looks like that and that parse is fine
I can parse something looks like that
and that parse is fine when I try to
parse something that looks like this
that used to work in Python 2 it doesn't
work anymore if this can't assigned a
keyword error now when I try to parse :
like giving a variable annotation to the
dot dot dot I get this error and when I
try to parse dot dot equals not at that
I get that error now I'm kind of curious
but I don't know a whole lot about how
Python works so I might just start
grepping for those errors and see what I
can find and when I grew up for the
first error illegal target for
annotation I can find this in the source
code this is the ast code for Python if
I scroll around a little bit I can kind
of see what's going on here it's not too
hard here if I scroll up to the top of
what this function is this is some
function that's used for validating
recording the ast for an expression
statement and you can see that when you
do an assignment the left-hand side of
assignment can only be a couple of
things it can be a name kind and
attribute kind but it can't be anything
else because otherwise you get a legal
target for this is an annotated
expression illegal target for annotation
and if you look you can see the same
reasoning for assignment for keywords
for example if you look for that
assignment to keyword you can see that
it also checks for forbidden names and
you can say oh this is why I can't
assign to true false or null it
specifically says oh is the name you're
trying to assign to true false or null
it's a forbidden name you get that error
but the weird thing is when you look for
can't assigned to ellipses your grip
doesn't give you anything let's try that
again there's nothing there and when you
look for can't assign that error there's
nothing there either and so you're kind
of curious but you're precocious you're
smart and you know you can always dig
deeper and one way that you know you can
dig deeper is find something that you
know will get hit run it under a
debugger so what we're gonna do is we're
just going to go back here and what we
saw here was this ast error why don't we
just put a breakpoint on AST err try
some
that we know will fail and then see what
happens there we go we hit our break
point let's look at a back trace of that
and we can kind of see where we are here
we have the ASD err can't assign to
ellipses okay in a st dot C 681 that's
defined by that's called from sick from
set context and if we go to that line we
can see why we couldn't grep for it this
mayor this error message is actually
automatically constructed because
there's a couple of things you can't
assign to and they just automatically
construct this now if you look a little
bit higher here you can see what's going
on which is every time you try to do an
assignment it depends on the context and
what you're doing the assignment when it
does this set context that looks and
sees is this a valid assignment and in
this case it's not so you get that can't
assigned to a Lipsey's message now one
thing that's interesting is that doesn't
answer why we can't assign to the dot
dot as a single Unicode character if we
go back to the error that we saw there
when we try to do the assignment to the
doctor as a single unit care care we get
a different error we get invalid
character an identifier now that's
something that we can grep for and if we
grep for that we see this line here
error input so if you scroll around
sorry if we yeah if we grep for this we
see quite a few answers here and we can
see in Unicode object dot C we have
invalid character now if we look around
a little bit and we can also see this
Python run invalid character identifier
and if we look at that it doesn't really
give us anything that interesting this
error shows up
here and this kind of shows up as like a
grab-bag of where errors get produced so
don't really tell us anything
interesting it's like error input so
some error function calls out here so
knowing that didn't really help us
instead what we're gonna probably want
to do is we're probably gonna want to
debug this and we'll just put a
breakpoint on their input and see what
happens
and we'll continue and then we'll try to
assign to the ten and we'll see what the
back trace of that looks like and that's
not actually very useful because it
turns out that whatever was stopping us
from assigning to the dot dot dot is a
single unicode character it's called
directly from the parser into Python run
doesn't tell us any information about
where we got stopped but we know a
little bit about compilers so we go back
to the basics and we say you know what I
know that I've looked at the grammar
I've looked at the parser there's
something else that's missing the
tokenizer
the thing that turns the individual
characters into the tokens that get fed
into the parser to generate the ast and
if I look at the tokenizer there's a
function called token get and if I look
through that I can kind of try and
figure out that there if I scroll down a
little bit I can see there's a function
called is potential identifier start
that's kind of useful and if I scroll
down a little bit more I can see a
function called is potential identifier
character and I can see a function
called verify identifier I don't even
know what these things do but it looks
kind of interesting and if I if I try
and figure out where those functions
define they're actually defined at the
top of this file and I look at that I
say is potential identifier start so
this is trying to determine if a python
variable name has a valid starting
character and a valid continuing
character well this says any Python
variable name starts with the letter
between a and Z ASCII lowercase a and
Zed ASCII uppercase or anything above
128 you know these are unicode
characters of course they're larger than
one say if they can't fit into a single
they're not ASCII characters they don't
fit into the ASCII code page same thing
with his potential identifier so that's
not a valid lead but if I go in to
verify identifier I may see something
kind of interesting and verify
identifier if I scroll down a little bit
I see PI Unicode is identifier well
that's kind of interesting because I
might have actually seen this in use
before
when I was bored one day I probably did
a dir on a string and I saw a bunch of
stuff in here that I probably never
really used like dot L just are just but
there's a is like gonna fire right in
the middle there and it turns out that
Python can actually tell you is a string
a valid Python identifier Oh X Y Z is a
pipe is a valid Python identifier this
string is a valid Python identifier
right that's not so I've gotten a little
bit closer and I can see how Python
helps me in this regards I've gotten a
little bit closer but what I need to
know is what happens there now you can
see here hi Unicode is identifier let's
go into PI Unicode is identifiers and
see what's going on there so here I have
the code for a PI Unicode is identifier
and suddenly I see something quite
interesting pepped 31 31 usually I don't
care about peps I don't read them I just
use the features but let me actually dig
in the documentation and see what this
thing is all about and it turns out if I
look at the pep for this if I look at
the pep for this I can see at 31 31
supporting non ASCII identifier z' look
at the author and try and guess why it
is that he really wanted to get this pep
in I want you to notice one thing I want
you to notice is look at his look at his
name and look as email address do you
ever wonder why French people when they
write their names and email addresses
they don't swap out the accident GU or
the Cydia for some other repeated
character German people will change the
moon ladder into an OE
or they'll change it s set into an SS so
French people really care about this
idea except when it comes to writing
emails to them don't ask me why that is
I told you this this talk has no theme
now we might know a little bit more
about what this thing is talking about
if we look at this you can see it goes
on and on and on it's a really long pep
it's incredibly boring and in here
somewhere
it mentions this thing X ID x ID
modifications XID start XID continue and
I know a little bit about Unicode I know
there exist these things called Unicode
categories and I might have seen them
before
a way for you the Unicode standard to
categorize characters so you know if I
look at a couple of interesting
characters like this I can see that if I
look at a couple of interesting Unicode
characters like this I can see the
lowercase a is an ll letter lowercase
the uppercase a is an L u letter
uppercase the number one is a number
probably d for decimal I'm guessing the
one half is a number other and that nut
on the end is a Pio function other but
none of this seems to refer to whether
it can be part of a valid Python
identifier or not now what other thing I
might know about Python identifiers is I
can actually write them out so you know
we have our Lipsey's but I can actually
write out my ten fires and Python
strings like this and so as I start to
play around with unicode one thing I
might want to do is I might want to
print out if I'm working in optical
engineering there's a lot of special
Greek letters that are used to reference
this and that and I might not be able to
type them on my keyboard so I can use
the slash and in order to type them now
before we go on I want to ask you one
very important question when it comes to
unicode there is only one thing you ever
need to know about Unicode it is what it
is the most famous most popular most
important unicode character in the world
what is the pinnacle of Unicode the apex
of the standard the most important
unicode character ever created obviously
now now the reason why the reason I
really wanted to bring that up for you
is as I told you this talk is a real
talk that took an enormous amount of
time to put together
and it's very important for you to
understand why it is that the talk
exists as it does the reason is we're
running PI data in New York this year on
a weekday which means many of you have
taken valuable time off from work to
come to this event to see talks like
this and many of you may have taken off
three days of work to see all the talks
to yesterday today and the tutorials
tomorrow and your coworker will come to
you tomorrow or Monday and ask you how
was PI data how did it work out you see
any good talks and you're gonna say to
them well I saw a couple of talks about
desk and number and then there was this
one talk that was about so maybe when
they asked you if you saw any good talks
of PI data maybe skip this one now when
you go back to pep 31:31 you might
realize that it's very much in depth but
you kind of look at your watch you look
at the time it's five o'clock it's time
to go home that's enough for today
but when you come back the next day
you've exceeded their expectations your
boss is out on an off-site you don't
really have any tasks today you're left
to your own devices and you go back to
that pep and you you kind of scroll
through it and you say there's some
links at the bottom and there's this
link here derived core properties and
that might give me some insight into
what's this X ID thing is it's just one
text file and if you look through it and
you look for X ID start you can see if
the Unicode standard actually gives
these these derived properties like tags
for every range of Unicode characters
and these are all the Unicode characters
that are valid as part of an identifier
the start of an identifier and if you
scroll down these are all the ones that
are valid as part of the continuation of
Unicode identifiers and you have some
free time so let's write a little bit of
code to parse that file will download it
will parse it and we'll see what is a
valid Python variable name that's where
we got to in the first place we couldn't
do dot equals dot dot dot no matter how
we typed it so let's see what we can do
well we're looking for everything that
look for the beginning of a character so
we'll just look for everything where X
ID start isn't it
there we go so here's all the XID starts
now we'll just grab the value out of
this we'll just grab the value out of
that part okay so those are all the
values and if it's a range and these are
hex values so there we go so those are
all the ranges there otherwise we'll set
these to the same and then we can just
go through these now we can see if
there's anything interesting here now if
we put these out we probably want to
print out the hex value just in case
somebody asks you for that we'll print
out the name of the character and I'll
print out the character itself and we'll
see is there anything interesting in
here anything that we can use to
basically waste the time to the boss
gets back from vacation then we'll put a
little sleep at the end here just just
so that when we print this out to the
screen okay so we've seen those as part
of identifiers as before Latin small
characters and upper characters and
takes a while for us to get past these
so you know what we're gonna do we're
just gonna skip anything with Latin in
the name and we get to see some very
interesting things that Python allows to
be valid identifiers in according to X
ID star and X ID and a lot of different
characters but you saw those modifiers
and that's very interesting because it
turns out that a couple of things are
valid in a Fire's here's a joke when I
gave the first version of the talk that
nobody liked but I liked a lot so the
double struct capital N no I want to do
so the double struck capital n is a
valid Python identifier that thing let's
see if I can get this these some of
these are very hard to type that one
there that's a validator fire the double
struck capital Z is also a validate and
fire that's one the capital R is also a
valid Python identifier which means that
if you wanted to be really tedious you
could write something like that right
and the job I really liked the joke I
really liked was this because type
annotations have to be useful for
something
now this isn't valid now this isn't
valid but thank goodness we have from
future import annotations so I like that
joke I don't know what nobody else did
what's really interesting is other
things are valid Python identifiers as
well like the Greek small letter PI and
the idea graphic number zero so this
should be valid Python let's take a look
for some reason this works but it
shouldn't why not
well that PI R squared shouldn't
actually work there let's take a look
and see what's happening because that's
not in our list that's not in our list
right and something weird is happening
here because on that line there I forgot
to type the squared as an uppercase and
it still worked and it works both ways I
wonder why that's possible well it turns
out that Square character is not X ID
start it's not excit continue it's a
it's a numeric other doesn't have that
tag at all and if we go back to what we
know which is that we have the standard
here and in this standard is very boring
standard it tells us about what is a
valid Python identifier X ID start or X
ID continue and it goes on into more
detail and it says here again X ID
continue closes the set under nfk see
normalization it turns out that python
will also try to normalize your
identifiers and nfk c normalization if
you read about normalization is one of
the very normalization forms here you
can see an example of it from Unicode
document and a
pose it than a recomposed it in order to
get a canonical form for these
characters and it turns out that that's
something that's done as part of your
Python identifiers now if you go into
Unicode data and you look at the
normalized function you can see it here
unicode data you see denormalize and if
you try to figure out if that thing is
ever actually used we might go back into
our gdb and put a breakpoint on that
right and we might continue and we can
see if we do X equals 10 y equals 10 it
doesn't get used so it doesn't get used
if your variable name has only ASCII
identifier but the moment I do that hold
on a second
it didn't get hit so it didn't try to
normalize it it still gave me this
invalid character identifier but if I
try to do this with something that I
know is a valid Python identifier like
an inter punked valid and X ID continue
it does get hit and I can look at a back
trace and I can see where I am and if I
look at that back trace I see you know
code data you see denormalized gets
called from pi method raw fast called
nicked blah blah blah blah blah
something interesting right here new
identifier and if I track that down and
I see where I am I can see that there's
a function called new identifier a new
identifier is what actually performs a
normalization well in the original code
it was NK n FK C will just make three
edits to make any n n FK C 2 n FK D and
go back into our old friend is Unicode
identifier and just comment out the part
where a checks of its X ID continue and
recompile our python interpreter then
anything is possible and so it's right
surprising that that just works and so
now I have a Python interpreter where
anything's a rat valid variable name
including x squared which is equal to X
2 because you know sometimes you're lazy
and you want to write a big sometimes
you want to write it small and it's up
to you and when you take that back home
with you you'll remember you know this
is valid Python
this is valid Python now we know that
this is valid Python as well right now
we know that up we have to do from
future import annotations and I need to
fix this sorry that was invalid Python
this needs an arrow there we go
thank you there we go
so that's valid Python and we know that
we can add some intro Punk's in here
some middle dots so that's valid Python
and if we look really closely we can see
some other really interesting stuff like
modifier letter prime is uh also x ID
continued so that's valid Python that's
a prime not a quote take that to work
with you and it turns out a whole lot of
interest in things are valid Python
syntax that you never expect them to be
and so you know at the end of the day
you might end up with something kind of
interesting it might look like something
like this makes total sense I mean this
is all valid Python syntax pythons a
very easy language you know it's not
syntactically very difficult to
understand anybody can really parse it
but just by looking at it it's not as
bad as any of that other stuff and
really really honestly let's be let's be
honest with ourselves this is quite
obvious because if you look at it
closely it's just a function named F
that has a single argument that's named
underscore that has a variable
annotation that is a twice plus the
unpacked dictionary of a dictionary that
map's on ellipses to and negated
ellipses raised to the power of a double
underscore that returns as part of its
function annotation a dictionary that
map's ellipses to ellipses that just has
as its only expression in it a variable
that has a bunch of interpunct and a
dotted lookup whose variable annotation
is a ellipses map to an ellipses what
could be simpler and you know what look
at the time it's five o'clock it's time
to go home
thank you so much
[Applause]
that's it there's no questions
[Laughter]